emmanuel macron a voulu remettre les
choses au clair il n'a aucune
complaisance envers la russie mais les
négociations restent selon lui le seul
moyen de mettre un terme à la guerre en
ukraine à un moment donné quand nous
aurons aider au maximum à résister quand
je le souhaite le crès n'aura gagné
surtout que le feu pourra cesser nous
devrons négocier
président ukrainien ses dirigeants devra
négocier avec la russie pour son premier
voyage aux portes de l'ukraine le
président français a passé en revue ses
troupes déployées dans cette base de
l'otan située au bord de la mer noire il
a rappelé le soutien sans faille de
l'union européenne envers les ukrainiens
mais lorsqu'on les interroge sur un
possible déplacement à kiev emmanuel
macron botte en touche aux portes de
notre union européenne se joue une
situation géopolitique inédite donc oui
pour toutes ces raisons le contexte
politique et les décisions de l'union
européenne et l'internation devront
prendre
justifie de nouvelles discussions en
profondeur et de nouvelles avancées
alors que la france occupe la présidence
de l'union européenne emmanuel macron
reste à ce jour l'un des rares
dirigeants européens à ne pas s'être
encore rendue en ukraine